the smartest minds on the planet have
had most of their time taken up arguing
about whether men and men and women are
women
over the last few years like me if
that's not the way to send our
civilization
back a couple of generations in terms of
the development of where it could be you
know i said about like
imagine the person that you could be if
you went sober for six months
like imagine the civilization we could
have if we stopped debating
stupid [ __ ] for a decade
cool so look before we begin this is
going to be an absolute roller coaster
because
i like to pride myself uh with having a
bit of a narrative when it comes to the
guests i speak to we kind of start in
the early days move through to what
they're currently doing
it almost feels like there's a nice
story there but i've listened to
250 if not more of your podcast so i
feel like i know far too much
to have a narrative here so before we
begin just
prior warning this is going to jump from
one topic to another
really quite quickly but where i want to
begin is
actually how i discovered you because i
discovered you entirely by accident
in a place that i never thought i would
discover the content that you produce
which is on a video
about love island there i was in our
office back in cardiff
typed into youtube behind the scenes
love island and there was this video
that
just recently been published of you and
two guys sat on a sofa talking about
love island and i clicked on it
and truthfully i thought i'd stay for
about four minutes i thought [ __ ] sake
one of these
another one of these guys just trying to
milk his attention um but actually what
i found was
the complete opposite so i clicked onto
your channel i think i watched a video
of don mcgregor and a couple of others
and i realized that you were actually
the exact opposite to every stereotype i
had created about you in my mind right
you are the
ex-love island club promoter with a
six-pack and a blue tick
and i thought [ __ ] sake but actually
you're this incredibly
uh curious person who uses your platform
not to try and sell booty
but actually just to have conversations
right and so
in the midst of living in all of those
stereotypes i just described when was it
you realized that you
weren't that guy that's a good question
i
didn't quite have an existential crisis
on love island but it certainly
catapulted me toward one
um i spent a lot of time with people who
genuinely are the person i thought i was
these guys with endless charisma that
are built to be party boys
and that's the role that i thought i was
playing
but it didn't necessarily turn out that
way and when i was given this fatal dose
of contrast i had to live with them
right for three weeks
and i just realized right that's not me
it was a fortunate time
jordan peterson and joe rogan and sam
harris and ben shapiro everybody was
coalescing
it was about a year before bill c-16
jordan peterson's thing it's two years
before evergreen state college for bert
weinstein
and there's just this whole slew of
mindful content coming out
so i jumped into that and thankfully
managed to
pull my head back above the parapet
didn't drown uh
in introspection and self-reflection and
then yeah here we are
take me on that journey right so you i
guess i'm making a big assumption here
but i guess you lived within
this kind of this collection of
stereotypes through the the modeling the
instagram the love island all of these
things
was there ever a point where you thought
[ __ ] i need to almost step away from at
least my presumed identity
to become the person that i actually am
very much so i've got a tedx talk coming
out this sunday
actually and this is the topic of the
talk you can bury yourself
under so many personas that you
genuinely don't know who you are anymore
and that's a real thing like you can
compromise your view
so many times because you want to be
liked by people right it was born out of
a place of
insecurity and a lack of confidence i
wanted to be liked by people
so much that i said whatever i thought
they wanted to hear from me
and i'd continue to do that over and
over and over again
until eventually i didn't actually know
what my opinion was
anymore i'd kind of habituated this
second
order metacognition way of answering a
question
um based on what i thought the response
was
so yeah it was difficult introspective
work
is like turning over dirty stones in
your back garden like for every one that
you turn over that's clean
19 of them are filthy and have something
terrifying hiding underneath
but it's worth it over time it really is
and
if i was ali abdal or if i was some
other productivity guy i would have had
a much
more curated organized developmental
strategy for how i could have done this
but i'd i'm not organized in that way so
i just relied on crushing
volumes of mindful introspective content
i had a lot of long drives to do there
might be people listening who have got
huge commutes or they you know 45
minutes to and from work every day
you will accumulate if you spend that
time listening to the right stuff
you can accumulate a terrifying amount
of content
at 1.5 times speed you will get through
ridiculous amounts of content
and that's what i did i had big drives
to do i was driving for maybe you know
five or six hours a week
every week sometimes more and um
yeah it was it was oddly i look back on
it quite fondly now at the time it just
felt like i was
drowning losing the person that i was i
wasn't this club promoter anymore
i mean i was that was my job but that
wasn't my identity that wasn't who i
wanted to be
and i think there comes a time
especially with guys girls i've i get
the impression figure themselves
out a little bit earlier but with guys
they hit the menopause
as i've done it dubbed it or the fitness
menopause for just the fitness side of
things
and they reach their late 20s and they
realize that the things which they used
to
spend their time doing and the sort of
values that used to consume them
really don't scale they don't work
anymore look i'm 28 years old
i can't be excited about every single
weekend getting a bag in with the lads
and going out on the lash
that's just not where i wanted to be and
letting go of that past version of you
is actually quite difficult
we live in these epochs right you've got
student chris and then club promoter
chris and young businessman chris and
young dad chris
and marry kristen blah blah blah but
then it's quite hard
to let go of that because you don't
really know what's next and it's even
harder if you've been hiding that
version of you
under a bunch of other personas so you
don't actually know which one it is like
who am i letting go of
am i letting go of this or this or this
or this and you have to excavate it out
like an archaeologist
so it was challenging and incredibly
worthwhile
i i'm very very thankful for the past
version of me for doing what has allowed
the future version of me
to live the life that i do so
if somebody's listening to this and they
think that maybe their values who they
are who they present themselves to be is
a bit out of date and they're not
actually
living a true version of themselves how
how does somebody
given that you've been for it right how
does somebody cultivate that that
fertile ground
to be able to give themselves permission
to change who they are on
quite fundamental levels um there's a
reason i asked this right because
i produced produced as a strong word
this was pre
uh content production days i made a
video a couple of years ago on instagram
ig tv
and i basically said that paraphrasing
here but if you're not
slightly embarrassed of the person you
were two years ago it means one of two
things the first is that you've
worked everything out and you're living
like your absolute best self which is
very unlikely well the second is that
you're not progressing at a sufficient
rate relative to what you could be which
is
very likely and there were two clear
camps of people
who reacted to that video right it was
campaign was people who were like yeah
cool i get it i'm on board
and can't be were almost like deeply
offended i dare suggest that people
should be progressing
it seems like people hold on to who they
are in the present or maybe even the
past
so much because they don't want to let
go how would you give yourself
permission to let go
it's very common people quite rightly
should be and are terrified of someone
telling them
that they should be embarrassed by the
person they were a couple of years ago
because it highlights their lack of
growth
this is the issue if you're the person
that likes to improve and likes to
change and likes to do different things
your friends if they're not
growth-minded and if they're a bit
immature and juvenile
they'll bring it up they'll say like oh
are you
going to go and read more books or you
[ __ ] swat like
what is this like are we 12 years old
now but why is it like what is it that
they're saying they're saying
you are moving away from me i can't keep
up
so i'm going to try and claw my way to
drag you back down
to what it is the same thing happens if
anyone tries to go sober it's difficult
because your friend said hang on
why are you not drinking the subtext in
that is do you think you're too good to
waste your life with us
that's what people are saying um
in terms of how can people get over that
inertia man it's it's
unbelievably difficult and i don't
really know
i don't really know what caused it for
me i actually think this is one of the
times where trauma can be useful
if you have a a really messy breakup i
had a couple of messy breakups so i'd
just been a prick
i just hadn't treated the girls well i i
class myself as a recovering fuckboy
and i don't think that they would my
exes would disagree too much either
actually
i'd spent a lot of time treating girls
pretty poorly just
classic young lad behavior nothing out
of the ordinary but just being a
prick and a couple of those really got
to me
and i thought like is this the person
that you want to be
like breaking young girls hearts that
have done nothing wrong
and that that that was part of it
people need to really spend time
if they want to go on this journey if
you want to change the person that you
are
fundamentally you have to know that this
is a lifelong pursuit
this isn't something that is going to
happen in six years
this is something that's going to happen
in 60 years
you can't just
booty blast booty [ __ ] like
juice cleanse your way through this and
given the fact that it's such a long
project
planning it and sitting down before you
start makes sense so
take some time to think about who is the
sort of person that i want to be
what is it that i do in my life at the
moment that isn't aligned
with that person what is it that i do in
my life that is aligned with that person
i'm not massively good at doing long
like 25-year
50-year plans what you want written on
your obituary
type thing like i'm not particularly
good at that but i do think that asking
yourself those questions gives you a
good sense of perspective
so ask them like what is it that you
want to be doing in 30 years time
that's a genuinely good question to ask
yourself because it highlights
the incongruence between what you're
doing now and where that vision takes
you
okay i i want to be um
working with people in child care
because i really think that the
education system needs to be reformed
i really want to do okay are you in any
way associated with that now
i want to be a family man okay well are
you [ __ ]
three girls a week and then ignoring
their texts after
after they reply to you okay well i mean
that that's also not going to work
so we very rarely sit back and actually
look at the components of our life
you don't actually think how am i
spending my days
and the problem is that life's quite
short life is far far shorter than
everybody realizes
you just don't have that many days
anymore
adding a sense of urgency adding a
realization that this
is all there is there isn't anything
else
the only reason you are here is to live
a life
which in retrospect you are glad that
you lived
that's it i want to pick up on something
you said there because i know that
you've been big on this recently i saw a
post of yours maybe yesterday about
post-traumatic growth is that the phrase
so a bit of a tangent but this this
almost explains the the turning point in
my life right so
um five or six years ago
um i was like running businesses but it
wasn't anything serious
and i my mum and i could kind of tell
that my dad
something was wrong with him i've cut a
very long story short he was eventually
diagnosed with alzheimer's
and it was at that moment when i
realized like nothing is going to be the
same again
period that that is what forced me to
ask those big questions that you just
mentioned right it was what forced me to
ask
am i actually living in accordance with
the the the values
that i want to am i heading towards
where i want to be heading
and it literally like a binary switch as
soon as i realized the answer that was
no
i just i changed everything what did you
change what were the biggest changes you
made
this sounds so bad but i i would be far
busier trying to look like i'm being
productive online than actually working
right
that meant the business was going
nowhere i would be far busier trying to
look like i had money to people i know
than trying to earn money that means my
finances are going nowhere
i would be far busier trying to live the
like party boy lifestyle and go out
every weekend
because i thought that that's what
fulfillment felt like rather than
building real
long-term fulfillment and you know i'd
maybe i'm post-rationalizing but i can
almost directly attribute to that moment
when i realized
[ __ ] like the first 19 years of life
they were fun they were great
but like now i need to switch on
immediate and irreversible
and so i think that you know
particularly for anyone who's going
through
their own unique difficult challenge
right now
it is an incredible catalyst to just to
ask yourself who you are i think because
you know that you get maybe two or three
opportunities in your life to look at
yourself that deeply
and if you miss them you miss them
congratulations man i'm really happy for
you that
i mean your intellectual awakening and
casting off of the
trappings of a fuckboy happened nine
years
eight or nine years earlier than mine so
you're ahead of the game
uh so i want to actually go back to your
uh let's call them your fuckboy days
right i saw you update your twitter bio
recently it's a recovering fuckboy
because
something else that is a bit of a
paradox with you is
your broad stance on alcohol right from
the the pie boy lifestyle that i guess
you lived and the reality shows but more
importantly than that the fact that
your company voodoo events i think
you've heard i've heard you say in the
past has
literally welcomed through the doors of
clubs over a million people
and essentially encouraged them to get
drunk and yet
over the past few years particularly
most recently i think you've done about
two years sober
you've cast away alcohol and looked at
the benefits of not drinking for a while
so
i guess my question here is twofold
firstly talk to me about
your lived benefits of not drinking but
then also
tell me through your eyes having been in
the nightlife industry basically since
you were of legal drinking age
what can you tell us about society's
wider relationship with alcohol
the benefits that you get from stopping
drinking alcohol
as far as i'm concerned stopping
drinking is the biggest competitive
advantage that everybody is leaving on
the table
except for sleep if you take two
versions of your universe in one of them
you continue to drink twice a week for
the rest of your life
in the other one you drink once every
two months the one where you drink once
every two months
is so much further ahead than the other
one
and it compounds as well
i the main the big three the key three
benefits is more time more money and
more calories to spend on things that
you truly care about
you're not wasting time being drunk on a
night you can finish your night you can
go out
sober you can finish your night at 1am
get a taxi or drive home
and wake up having enjoyed i would guess
probably 70 percent
there is some enjoyment that comes from
alcohol and we'll get on to this in a
bit that's why i'm not
a sobriety absolutist and i'm also not
going to be
sober for the rest of my life sobriety
is a productivity tool not a way of life
as far as i'm concerned
you can have go out do the pre-drinks
you're having soft drinks
go to the pre-bar you doing whatever
with your friends you still get to enjoy
all the social stuff you're not quite as
loose you're not quite as lairy
and then you get to leave at one in the
morning maybe you're a little bit tired
you know you've got an 8 a.m wake up in
the morning you're still gonna be a
little bit fatigued
but you are a world apart from everybody
else they are dying they're ordering the
dominoes the next day
when you get drunk you're essentially
electing to be ill
for 24 hours and sometimes people do
that
numerous times a week just throwing
themselves out of their diet
throwing themselves off their training
their productivities out of the window
their will powers through the floor
and this is just accepted as a part of
society not only is it accepted it's a
right of passage
for young people it is what you do as a
young person it's how you bond with
those that are around you
it's how you create the stories that
allow you to relate to people when you
get older
hey man tell me tell me about some
you've been to vegas haven't you tell me
about some crazy times when you've oh
you've been
you've been to manchester haven't you
tell me about some crazy times when
you're in manchester
these stories are worn like badges of
honor and i'm fine
if you want to grow up in 2021 you need
to go out and party
because that's what allows you to relate
to other people my problem is when
someone does that
every week week in week out for decades
at the time
if you're 40 years old and the height of
your life is getting a bag in with the
boys on a weekend
and getting off your face that's a life
wasted as far as i'm concerned
and i'm all for simple pleasures but i'm
for simple pleasures that allow you to
grow as a human not one that stagnates
you and keeps you in the same place
so more time more money obviously not
spending money on
the alcohol not spending money on the
takeaways the next day it allows you to
work more because you have more time you
can work more which earns you
more you only need to work 10 more to
earn
40 percent more money that's a jordan
peterson quote um
and then more energy to spend on things
you have the consistency
right you're able to do difficult things
it's hard enough to instantiate habits
already now add a hangover on top of it
it's basically [ __ ] impossible
right you can't do anything so those are
my main benefits there are
so many others it forces you to develop
genuine confidence
going sober means that you have to be
properly
confident because you can't rely on
dutch courage to get you to go over to
that girl
on the other side of the club if you
want to go and speak to that guy or girl
over the other side
and you're sober you either have to
develop the confidence to go and do it
naturally
or not speak to them and if you want to
get laid if you
if you're doing six months sober and you
want to have sex at some point during
those
six months you're either going to pound
tinder or learn to speak to people
and i realized very quickly upon going
sober just how much of what i considered
confidence
was buttressed very heavily by alcohol
take that buttress away and i had to
properly develop it
it's like the guy that's on
performance-enhancing drugs so well how
strong are you without the drugs you go
well
not as strong i wouldn't compete quite
as well so
that's the same thing you are forced to
be more selective with the sort of
events that you go to
because you don't you can't anaesthetize
yourself
from [ __ ] events by being drunk
if you get invited out to do something
and you don't really care
whether it's good or not because you
know that as long as you can get five
pints and a couple of vodkas in you
it's gonna be fun in any case and you
probably won't remember how bad it is
you're not gonna be very picky it also
forces you to really look at the people
that you're spending your time with
if the only way that you can spend time
with your friends
is by being drunk then you definitely
need better friends
um so there's some i could go on dude i
could do
20 of these advantages right but
all of the things that people want in
life more money more energy
more calories more time all of those
things can be got by going sober for a
period
my advice my prescription is six months
every five years uh two months every two
years and 28 days every year
so you can build that up however you
want but
there are people on this planet who from
the day that they turn of legal drinking
age until the day that they die will not
go for more than two weeks without
putting that drug into their system
and if you said that about anything else
other than caffeine
they would look at you like your mental
even if you said it was paracetamol or
ibuprofen someone would look at you and
say
well that's that doesn't sound very
healthy mate what every two weeks
every two weeks i managed to piss off
both the sobriety community and the
drinking community within the space of
about two days a couple of years ago
the drinking community especially
promoters
have an issue with me talking about
sobriety and rightly so because i'm
red pilling the audience that is their
market on why they don't need
to consume their product or my product
but that's not necessarily true because
we make money on the door not on the bar
and i'm more than happy to charge people
to get in
whether they're drinking soft drinks or
not um so
those people weren't happy someone
scrolled back
to 2016 to a time when i was doing
a gig for grey goose and managed to find
a photo of me holding a bottle because i
was saying
like the height the height of spending
your weekend is not holding a bottle in
a club
fair play to the people that went back
and did that because i was like well you
know that's that's the
like the the dick pic nude that's
lurking around on the internet that was
like my alcoholic equivalent of that
um but then i went and gave a talk at a
sobriety festival
and as with a lot of things at the
moment the collapse of grand narratives
we don't have religion we don't have the
traditions that used to hold us together
people want to find their gods in
something else and
sobriety of the gaps it would appear is
now a thing
so the people that were there sober for
life a lot of them are recovering but
some of them aren't some of them are
elective as i would class myself but no
one was there talking about it as a
productivity tool
they would talk about the advantages of
being sober that could contribute to
your productivity
but it wasn't there as a tool like
pomodoros or like deep work or like
using the first things first method
that's how i see it i see sobriety
as a competitive advantage tool that you
can use
as you need if you want to have more
money more time more calories
more energy to spend on things that you
truly care about cut out drinking
cut out drinking for six months and tell
me that you're not
worlds better so many people think that
the problem with their habits is the
fact that they're undisciplined or they
don't have focus or things are just too
hard
they don't realize that they're just
resetting their progress
every week or every two weeks by getting
off their face on a weekend
so i went i gave this talk i said um i'm
actually going to start drinking again
in
uh two weeks time and there was an
audible intake of
of air from the room like the pressure
of the room went and my ears popped
and um sure enough afterwards i put a
post up saying
i've completed this period of sobriety
i'm now going to start drinking
i garnered some followers from this
event and then immediately got a lot of
criticism saying that it's triggering
talking about reintroducing alcohol
it's something that shouldn't be spoken
about because people in the sobriety
community might be looking up to me as
an example for their sobriety
and i'm now saying that i'm drinking
again i was like i
i get it if you're a recovering
alcoholic then you shouldn't be looking
to reintroduce alcohol
but if you're recovering alcoholic i'm
not your role model
plus anyone that says that alcohol
doesn't make a night out better
hasn't had a good night out like i'm a
club promoter through and through
don't get me wrong for all of my zenny
mindful exterior and
the talks about physics and [ __ ]
psychology with jordan peterson
like i'm still a party boy at heart but
i'm a party boy that has grander goals
than just being a party boy
so what was my solution okay i'm going
to
the same way as a power lifter does
competition prep when he's got a huge
meat coming up
i treated my intake of alcohol in the
same way i have
some goals that i want to achieve
alcohol isn't facilitating those goals
i need to get rid of alcohol if that's
the price that i need to pay then fine
so i'm about to hit a thousand days
sober
um this is the current block i would
have broken this sobriety last year if
it hadn't been for the pandemic
because i'd i was ready i'd learned
everything that i had to learn from
being sober
right like i don't really have much else
to learn from it i don't think
um not at this point i've done it a lot
i've done two stints of six months
um and then i've done this thousand days
one and i've done it through summers
i've done it through winters i've done
it over christmas i've done it over my
birthday
i don't really have much else to learn
but the reason i stopped drinking was
because i didn't have anything else to
learn from
alcohol so moving between the two and i
appreciate that this is speaking from a
position
of privilege that i don't have a
dependency
on alcohol so i can bring it in and take
out of my life as i
as i wish but i've deprogrammed that
desire you do you
have the word clucking do you know what
cooking is i could desire for a drink
i'm looking for a drink on a friday
night that friday afternoon niche that a
lot of people get
deprogramming that was worth
all of the discomfort just getting rid
of that compulsion i don't know what it
feels like to want a drink anymore
even after the first couple of stints of
sobriety
when it was sunny outside and i drive
past a beer garden on osborne road which
is this famous road in jesmond in
newcastle with tons of bars and there's
gardens outside and
all the girls are in maxi dresses and
the guys are in shirts and everyone's
having a good time
called copperberg with ice and i just
thought like
that was still a bit of a compulsion but
after a couple of goes and then
especially this thousand days thing
i'm in complete control my relationship
with alcohol is now on my
terms and i don't i would be interested
to see how long
before i can habituate it back in the
alcohol is in control
i don't think i'm ever going to get back
to drinking in that particular mode
um so again all of this came about at
the same time
this intellectual awakening the mano
pause the fitness menopause with me
stopping doing bro lifting and starting
to do other things that facilitated my
health not just my physique
and then this sobriety all of this
happened at the same time
and i think perhaps that
is something else that people can
consider i know that
if you subscribe to the james clear
approach for habits that you should be
doing
small incremental goals focus on a
single habit at a time nail that and
then move on to the next one
i would maybe say that there's an
argument to be made for a wholesale
fire sale of everything okay let's just
strip all of the things that i do back
my entire routine can go out of the
window
and if you make a fundamental single
change like taking
alcohol out of your life it opens up so
much more because now
saturday daytime and sunday morning are
available to you
because now you have more money and more
time to spend on working and you can
build things
there is no way that i would have been
able to launch the podcast and do all
the [ __ ] that i've done over the last
three years if i was still drinking
not in a million years i'm already
working
close to my maximum level of capacity
i'd add hangovers in a couple of nights
out into that and i'd have been wrecked
so yeah i think um everybody would
benefit from a period of focused
sobriety
far more than they think and
i challenge anybody to do it and say
that their life
isn't better it takes a very very rare
human for that to be the case
it's interesting because i only ever
intended to do
actually i intended to do four days to
begin with it was the 4th of january
i had just had the most ridiculous
december like client parties mahiki
surfboard like wild [ __ ] right and i'm
like i don't feel too good about
drinking
this like january the 4th on a client
night out so i tweeted i'm like i wonder
if i could do
january without alcohol and the further
i
moved from that point of i couldn't
diagnose it at the time but looking back
you could probably call it anxiety
waking up a hangover feeling awful
blackout drunk just stupid situations
for example got myself mugged in london
at like 2 a.m in islington by two guys
can't even tell you what they look like
that's how blackout drunk used to get
like terrifying it was never supposed to
be this long-term thing but
as two things happen in tandem the
further away i moved from that point of
[ __ ] i didn't like that and the the more
benefits i reap
i can't ever see myself going back to
drinking and it's not for the same
reasons
as those who gasped as you gave your
talk because
i hold sobriety quite loosely you know
we have for example we have two alcohol
brands who are clients of ours i
actively
help sell alcohol and i have no issue
with it
it's just that once you have lived the
benefits of not drinking
it's very very hard to at least
dip your toe in the water of returning
to or at least it is for me it sounds
like you're
you're more liberal with it but for me i
just wonder whether
um in the same way that i accidentally
went down the path of not drinking if i
go back to it
will i be i think um
i think you'll be surprised after a
period of time if you're a curious
individual after a period of time
your curiosity around i wonder what
drinking is like
now will start to grow so strong
that you may not be able to control it
and that's
quite kind of where i'm at now i can't
switch that off i'm like i want to know
i want to know what i can't remember
what it feels like to be drunk i know
kind of like globally i know what it is
i don't actually know what it feels like
but yeah people are right to bring up
the fact how can you
promote nightclubs and talk about the
virtues of sobriety at the same time
and the reason is i'm a party boy at
heart i love events
i've booked to go and see abgt-450 in
london
at the dockyards i i like nights out and
i love being a promoter
but if you are approaching your 30s or
in your 30s
and you've never taken a break from
being a party boy or a party girl
i would like to think that there is more
for life more to life
for you and for those of us that are
growth-minded and want to do things and
don't just want to live with societal
programming and social
norms and genetic predisposition and
passive least resistance and all that
sort of stuff
if that's the case you need to make a
change and the easiest change that you
can make
is stopping drinking so you're in
a small minority of people who for the
past year or so haven't
drank right since lockdown but you're in
the overwhelming majority of people who
for the past
383 days did my research hasn't been in
a nightclub
because it was then when boris said that
you know barring a couple of
i think you guys did some actually
borrowing a couple of relatively
unnatural feeling events
um you haven't been able to work so as a
club promoter as somebody whose life
and livelihood revolves around the
hospitality industry talk to me about
the last
year and a bit how's it been the last
year has been challenging for the
nightlife industry
i think that most of the promoters that
i know
we can look like [ __ ] boys outwardly but
inwardly
everybody knew that we should have been
closed
no one's complained no one genuinely
believes that nightlife should be open
i know that sasha that runs parklife has
been
talking very loudly on twitter and
getting tons of clout from
talking about how hospitality isn't a
vector for transmission and all this
sort of stuff
but man like if gyms are shut
how the [ __ ] are you gonna convince me
that nightclubs need to be open and it's
my money
i own an events company and i don't
think that nightlife should be open
ahead of gyms
i don't think that nightlife should be
open ahead of non-essential shopping
that's not because i don't care about
nightlife it's because i understand
the way that public impression sees this
sort of thing
like nightlife going out on the lash
is not a necessity you can socialize
with people through other means
like what's called referred to as
vertical drinking so your dance flow
through your general admits
that is how anyone's going to try and
convince me that that's not a vector for
transmission
is insane people literally put their
mouths in each other's mouths
like it's obviously a vector for
transmission so anyway
it's been a challenging year for the
nightlife industry and
i think it's forced a lot of club
promoters venue managers bar staff djs
to take quite a hard look at what
they've been doing with their life
um i imagine that the last year would
have been good for a lot of people that
it would have made them question
i mean what am i doing i actually want
to be
in this industry do i want to be waiting
tables do i want to be a chef in a
restaurant do i want to be the manager
of a hotel
and from a business owner's perspective
that puts you a
position of risk because staff who
didn't want to be there but didn't know
that they didn't want to be there
may leave thankfully for us all of the
guys and girls that work for us
everybody's pretty much stayed on we
have a big staff base and we have a good
good bunch of managers all of them have
stayed which is great
but yeah man it's been a challenge it's
been difficult um
putting up with a pandemic as a club
promoter
is an existential risk but it's
permitted a lot of people to
find other hobbies to maybe re-center
how it is that they're going to work
and you know if the worst thing
if the price that we need to pay is to
be shut for a year when people are dying
left right and center and
businesses remember as well specifically
from a club
promoter perspective i'm not talking for
the operators here that own venues
we have no costs you have your office
maybe have a couple of guys that work
full-time that your managers and then
the rest of the staff are wrong
commission or they're on a zero hour
contract because their dancers or their
hostesses
or their guest listers or whatever like
life could be so much what about the guy
that's just bought the trampoline park
and decked it out and this is all of his
money and what about the fella that's
just decided to start up doing
a hairdressers or a boutique
nail salon or something like that these
places they've got
rent they've got rates they've got
business tax they've got all of this
sort of stuff
it's not been fantastic for us because
the front end of money in
hasn't been too good but it's not been
too bad for us because the back end of
money out hasn't been too bad
was there ever a moment in the past year
where despite knowing the things yes
will eventually get back to normal
you kind of felt yourself in a bit of a
hole like where do we go from here
with regards to the business there's
been some challenges
i think me and my business partner
specifically are in a good position
darren who is my business partner of 14
years has
two kids and a third one on the way he
has two dogs he has a
very big house that needs a lot of diy
doing to it
so he's had a lot to do over the last
year
if i hadn't had the podcast during the
pandemic
i would have been in a really bad place
but the podcast is my passion project
like i love running club nights i love
my business and that
hasn't changed but it's not where my
passion is like my
passion isn't in partying i like running
a good event
but my real true compulsion now what i
feel compelled to do
is have conversations with people like
this i won't have conversations with
people all the time
and that has been one of the anchors
that's dragged me through
the pandemic because i've been able to
do more
of what i like now i would have much
preferred to have been able to do more
of what i like and also earn the money
from nightclubs being open that would
have been great you know a hundred
thousand people not dying in the uk
would have also been lovely
and being able to go abroad and see my
friends and so on and so forth
but yeah i would i would go as far as to
say that the podcast
pretty much sort of saved my sanity over
the last 12 months because it's allowed
me to and it's not about
the the money that it earns it's not
about the growth it's about the fact
that i've had something that i can put
my passion into that's allowed me
to feel like i'm developing like i'm
contributing to something which is a
bigger project
and i feel for the people who haven't
had that
um if you don't have a
something that you contribute to that
feels like it's part of your wider goals
i can imagine the last year has been
been pretty challenging but if that's
the case
it's maybe made you take a stark look at
the way that your life is structured to
actually think oh
maybe i need to let me need to find
something
because maybe my passion was going out
and going on the lash with the boys on
the weekend
that's been taken away from me so now i
actually have to develop something which
isn't
buttressed by alcohol and party culture
or maybe i have to find something which
isn't no one can flex you know
it doesn't matter how much money you've
got or how flash the new car is
if you're only allowed to leave the
house to go to the shop kind of
mutes your ability to flex so i think
the last year oddly should have recented
people's priorities
and [ __ ] the bed if you're coming out of
this and you haven't had your
your priorities checked i think that
you've missed
the opportunity to learn a lesson from a
priority
alignment point of view is your
day-to-day going to look any different
when clubs reopen because yes modern
wisdom existed
pre-pandemic but you must have done 170
180 episodes
since lockdown began do you think that
you want to live the same day today in
the business might you take a step back
might things change or will it just be
you know that the necessity of making
money and running the business which is
something bigger than you
will take over once again where do you
stand on that good question
so my business partner's already taking
a bit more of a step up recently
which is great um he knows where my
availability availabilities at and i
still fill in and do the things that i
do
i think i've taken a step back from
working the night because
a 3am finish is difficult enough as it
is but at 33 years old a 3am finish is
it ends your world and in tomorrow night
from the night when we're speaking i've
got jordan peterson on the show
like if i'd been up till if i'm up till
three o'clock in the morning tonight
counting cash
and then i've got to try and hold water
with the quickest intellectual on the
planet
i'm not going to do very well everything
in my life right now
is geared toward me being the best
podcaster that i can
everything from my sleep to the things
that i read to the way that i construct
my habits to the way that my day is put
together that's all that i'm bothered
about that's all that i think about
now i don't actually think that running
a business
in nightlife is contrary to that i don't
think it necessarily takes away from
that i think that
maybe it can even contribute to it
because i'll have more stories to talk
about because i'll
vary the environment that i'm in which
will make me feel refreshed i get to go
into meetings and meet new people and
see new things and have different modes
of thinking and stuff like that
that's fantastic um yes there will be
some changes
but it will only be they'll be
structural not value-led i don't think
it's going to be i sort of turned pro
with the podcast around about a year ago
and um that was a that was a fairly big
turning point because it went from being
just a passion project to it being the
thing that i do
like my reason for being um
but the reintroduction of club nights
and nightlife i think for me will just
be
it'll just be nice man i i drove to
leeds yesterday and it felt like a
holiday
because that's how little i've left the
house shouldn't be the case that a trip
to leeds
three hours three and a half hours under
a1 feels like a treat
you know like okay what's the world come
to that that's my my idea
of an adventure i know that something
you were big on particularly in the
first lockdown is this idea
of asking yourself what would you need
to achieve
during this lockdown to consider it a
success and whilst i'm sure many people
took took that advice and ran with it
many
others inevitably didn't right as we
edge
closer and closer to normality as these
restrictions which take our freedoms but
give us time
are slowly pulled away from us if
somebody's listening to this and they
think actually i haven't
really achieved anything in the past
year or so
but i have the desire to do so now what
advice would you give to somebody to
make the most of these last few weeks
good question so you need to ask
yourself the question now
what would have to happen within the
next couple of weeks for you to look
back on this period
and consider it a success like genuinely
just think down and see
what would it be
there's silence if there's just nothing
there that's where you need to go first
like do you want to start a website do
you want to lose body fat do you want to
get up on time and build a new sleep and
wake habit do you want to read a couple
of books do you want to start meditating
do you want to reconnect with your
spouse and make the relationship less
[ __ ] do you want to do whatever it is
like pick
your thing and just do it jordan
peterson's new book
which obviously i'm balls deep in at the
moment in a desperate attempt to try
and get on his level ready for tomorrow
um he's got this
chapter i think it's chapter 10 uh where
he says um
try as hard as you can at one thing or
commit yourself as hard as you can to
one
thing and see what happens um
an element of that which i totally
didn't realize is that commit yourself
to one
thing part a lot of the time we don't
make a choice because we have
opportunity anxiety
around the things that doing that means
that we can no longer do
think oh well like it'd be great to do
meditation but that's going to take away
from my time in the gym so i'll meditate
for five minutes and i'll do the gym for
five minutes or an equivalent
or i'd love to um
make the relationship with my misses
better but i also know that there's
loads of
fit girls on tinder at the same time so
maybe maybe i'll try and
like warm her up a little bit but i'll
get back up girls on tinder to see just
in case it goes
crap if you just choose the thing
just pick the thing after this podcast
finishes
sit down and think what is a thing that
i want to do
what is something that i've been
thinking about it's maybe it's been in
the back of your mind it keeps on
repeating and repeating itself
i really need to x build a reading habit
habit stuff's going to be easier because
you're going to have fewer external
stimulus that come in
and knock you off your routine just pick
the thing
and never miss two days in a row for the
rest of lockdown that's it that's all
that you need to do
and by the end of it this is a gift that
you will give your future self
you now can give you in the future
the gift of the hard work that you're
going to pay
and then for the rest of your life
potentially you're going to build up
there's things that i did there's habits
that i instantiated and i'm sure there
are for you as well
three years ago four years ago i paid
the price for them
the activity inertia getting over the
discomfort at the very beginning
and i'm still reaping the benefits now
which is mental
like my meditation habit was built four
years ago i'm a thousand days deep now
and it feels harder for me not to
meditate than to meditate on a morning
so just do it what would make the next
few weeks of success
think about what it would be pick a
thing one thing
and just do that so here comes one of
those those big departures where what
i'm about to ask is nothing to do or
what i've just asked
um something i find myself having more
and more conversations about recently is
council culture because who isn't
talking about it right or the sense that
there's an abundance of outrage on the
internet and that you can't escape
it and you know notably jordan pearson
who you're speaking to tomorrow but a
lot of your other guests have been
victim of the twitter mob right and i
had tom harwood on here a few weeks ago
tom
was the senior editor at guido fawkes at
the time he ran the vote leave
um of a student vote leave arm and now
he's just gone to gb news right and just
before i sat down with him
um i did some in-depth research of
searching his name on twitter
and in the 24 hours before we sat down
to speak he had been tweeted just over a
thousand times there was like a plethora
of swears in there and i think two
people had called him a prick and
he explained to me that as soon as you
have any sort of
notoriety on the internet people um have
an image of who they think you are
they read everything through the
paradigm of that image
and then you instantly become a target
right and this is something i've heard
you speak about before i couldn't
actually find the tweet to reference it
but i remember maybe a year ago you
tweeted that you're almost just
holding your breath you're almost
waiting as as modern wisdom gets bigger
and bigger and bigger and as you reach
bigger guests you're almost waiting for
that story or that rumor or that claim
to creep out of nowhere
and try and stop you in your tracks so
firstly given that you've spoken to so
many people who are at the forefront of
this
quote-unquote culture war and everything
that comes along with it what is your
view on council culture
and with that in mind as modern wisdom
grows as tom suggested
do you think that people who have reach
or who have success has suddenly held to
a very different standard
no one cares what you say until you've
got clout
nobody gives a [ __ ] about you you can be
the most racist misogynistic homophobic
idiot prick on the internet if you've
only got three followers no one cares
what's the difference well it's that if
you have status
you should act in a way which is more
responsible
somehow maybe or you should show more
capability
perhaps something like that i think
because people see you with something
that they want
if you've got clout they think well hang
on he's got it or he's a he's a rival of
mine for the clout that i have maybe i'm
a bit further ahead of him or maybe
we're similar or whatever
um man this whole the whole cancel
culture thing i think
it's been i've had so many conversations
on my podcast about it
the best that i can see is that
cancel culture exists because people are
struggling to gain status
now and the easiest way to gain status
if you're someone that can't compete in
a meritocracy is to criticize status
structures as a whole
if you step outside of the status
hierarchy and
say criticize it wholesale
it almost feels like well i could be
anywhere within it but i don't care
about that game
because like you know that's that's
that's for the
miss andrey or the misogyny or the
patriarchy or the whatever you want to
pick whatever you want to say so i think
it's an ugly situation to watch unfold
moral grandstanding is a huge thing that
is an interesting insight actually
something that i learned the other day
the reason that people love scandal and
watching the takedown of people on the
internet
is because it allows them to feel a
moral emotion
superiority without having to actually
do anything moral
like if that's not the freest [ __ ]
lunch
that anyone's going to get i don't know
what is
you are allowed to feel moral because
no one is scrutinizing the things that
you do and
all that you need to do is scrutinize
something that someone else has done
and this is why i think internally man
so many of the people that jump on these
cancel mobs on the internet
don't bother reading what someone's done
don't bother doing their research just
dislike the person that's
tweeted see a couple of other tweets and
then decide to jump in
i think a lot of these people dislike
themselves fundamentally
i have never left a bad
youtube comment on someone's video ever
like if i want to call someone out for
something because i think that they're
being disingenuous or they don't have
integrity
i'm gonna do it in a way that they're
gonna see i'm just gonna con i'm not
gonna contribute to this
flood of sort of general malaise that
i'm just
throwing at them like that i'm not
bothered about that so
yeah the the cancel culture thing is
it increases in line with clout as
people become
more notorious the desire to take them
down
also increases in kind because if you
can be the person that finds
darren grimes secret racist tweet
like darren grimes is for people that
don't know he's a one of the
leaders of the leave movement when
brexit was happening
but he's also a working class lad from
durham so he's got a
broad northern accent and he's gay
and that's really disliked because
working class northern
gay should be super lefty
should be super labor should have been
remain uh and he wasn't
and people didn't like that about him so
they now try and find the things he
tweeted the other day
that he was leaving london for his
mental health because he was going back
home
and he got annihilated on the internet
people laughing about the fact that he
couldn't bear to live on his own
or poor darren wanted to leave the eu
but can't stay in the house on his own
blah blah blah
you think hang on i thought that the
left were the party of mental health
i thought you were the ones of
compassion and politeness and all this
sort of stuff
but no and the the point of that is that
people only want to adhere to their
highest virtues when it
suits them you know there were two exact
i've i've been so detached from caring
about this stuff until
it almost happened to two people i
follow closely recently right and
i'll give you both examples because i
think it just highlights exactly what
you just said and the ridiculous and
this
ridiculousness of this whole thing uh
the first was i won't name him but there
was a there's like a prominent
media entrepreneur in the uk young guy
and he
tweeted like a meme which could have
been misconstrued to like
make fun of domestic violence or
something he tweeted this picture
he removed it within about 40 seconds
right i just happened to be in the
office on my phone looked it saw it
[ __ ] out like whatever got on my day
an hour and a half later i opened
twitter again the tweet's obviously gone
and he's number two trend in the uk
and thousands of people were like
outraged
about something they didn't see and so
already i'm thinking this is a bit mad
and then a couple of weeks ago the
rapper dave um
the man who used the arguably the
biggest
reach performance of his career so far
to stand on the stage at the brits
and perform his song black which is
about being being proud of being black
right and he added in this verse at the
end which was like
is racist whether or not it feels racist
the truth is our prime minister's a real
racist all of these things like using
his platform
and then out of the blue the other night
someone found a tweet from when he was
15
and the whole of twitter blew up dave's
racist and i'm just like
surely [ __ ] not surely we're not
holding to a higher standard what
somebody said when they were 15
than the platform he had at the brits to
clearly show his stance on
you know being black and british and
just i i'm lost for words as to
how we've arrived here or even where we
go from here because you know i think
you hit the nail on the head which is
that
people see uh clout for another word as
a zero-sum game and the only way you
gain some is by taking it from somebody
else and
it's it couldn't be further from the
truth but yeah i don't know what i'm
going with that for it just it stresses
me
no man i think um
the vast majority of people that are
part of council culture mobs online
fundamentally dislike themselves inside
and they project their low self image
onto others
like what what are we actually trying to
do
when you see someone tweet a thing and
you then take that
one little sliver of their personality
to expand out to their whole being
you presume that this person is
unidimensional that this one tweet
is so representative that it is slap
bang in the bull's-eye
of this person's being oh no no the way
that he
cooks is racist the way that he sleeps
is racist
the way that he walks his dog is racist
everything that he does is
infused with this one tweet from
15 years ago or whatever it might be
when he was 15 years old
people are looking for that one thing to
extrapolate it out
because fundamentally the council
culture mob
believes that other people are like them
and that is someone that is living a
life which is
show on the front and internally
lacks virtue like if you i don't look at
someone and think that
any one thing that they did ever
is representative of even murderers get
out of jail
you know we don't say you the criminal
record's going to be with you for the
rest of your life but you're allowed to
leave the punishment
and yet tweeting something from 15 years
ago
isn't the case that's not the same we
need to hold
the actions of yesterday by the
standards of today that's what the
council culture mob thinks
and that's not true because the
standards of today change all the time
we don't know what in 10 years time is
going to be reprehensible that we're
still doing today
animal animal rights as one good example
i think it's probably safe to assume
that in a hundred years people will look
back on factory farming and think that
we were absolute savages
so if that's the case if ethics and
morality and
the way that values in a society change
so much
100 years ago the segregation of whites
and blacks
probably wouldn't have been i don't know
where i'm not a
race racial history expert but i imagine
that it wouldn't have been as big of a
deal as it is
now right they wouldn't have the same
levels of equality
that you do now so in 100 years time you
presuming that you know what's right now
is also the the what is it solipsism
the way you believe that you are the
only thing that matters and you are the
only one that knows
um yeah man i
those people aren't serious thinkers i'm
not interested in what those people have
to say
i'm bothered with trying to find
interesting insights
and it says a lot that someone who is
from the uk
that is pro most of the things that the
actual left is supposed to be for
ends up finding far more to talk about
with people that are center-right
um yeah it's interesting i
i kind of do get the impression that the
whole cancel culture thing will eat its
own tail
when you start to have intersecting
grievance hierarchies
inevitably it's self-defeating because
this person
doesn't just want to go against the
out-group there's also an in-group which
has been split off from them that's part
of another out-group
if it's like blacks versus whites then
surely it's also female blacks versus
male blacks
and then if it's female gay blacks
versus female straight blacks
and you just continue to slice and dice
every single hierarchy that you can
and it comes back to the fact that being
able to tear somebody else down
or find scandal about them allows you to
feel moral whilst having done nothing
moral yourself
so yeah i think inevitably it is going
to be self-defeating
and um just i hope it hurries up i'm
sick of having conversations woke
bashing as well man
i've had people like douglas murray on
the show and andrew doyle
these guys went to the best universities
on the planet
studying hardcore english literature
theater art like they understand stuff
about the history of human development
that is timeless and evergreen and yet
the smartest minds on the planet
have had most of their time taken up
arguing about whether men and men and
women are women
over the last few years like [ __ ] me if
that's not the way to send our
civilization
back a couple of generations in terms of
the development of where it could be you
know i said about like imagine the
person that you could be
if you went sober for six months like
imagine the civilization we could have
if we stopped debating stupid [ __ ] for a
decade
so i want to end here um which is uh i
love reading books because you can
essentially take a lifetime's worth of
learning from a person
and what consume it in 10 hours you've
spoken to
an awful lot of authors and awful lot of
interesting people of modern wisdom
and you know without exaggerating here
and i'm sure you'll agree you've
literally spoken to some of the smartest
most interesting and most unique
thinkers on the planet right
so as you've just reached 300 episodes
300 conversations
taking everything you've learned and by
the way you can make this answer as long
as you want
um imagine that you're writing your own
book you're an author now
what are the chapters that need to be in
there what are the lessons you've
learned from those 300 people
that you now live with and that you need
to give to other people
what a question right okay this is a
magnum a magnum opus um
if i was to write a book right now i
think it would be advising people
to deprogram the things that they don't
actually want to want from their life
and some of the principles that they
would need to get past with that
one chapter would be called don't
practice
what you do not want to become to jordan
peterson quote
you do not have the choice around
whether or not you make a habit
you simply get to choose what habit you
make
so if you decide to hit the snooze
button that's not
just not getting up early that's she's
choosing to get up late that's embedding
the habit of being a person that gets up
late don't practice what you do not want
to become
that would be one of them um life
is dissatisfaction is another one life
is
unsatisfactoriness actually would be the
technically correct thing
so the buddha said um life is suffering
but
the suffering word dukkha d-u-k-k-h-a
has been contested by some scholars is
actually being
unsatisfactoriness what does that mean
it means that
you are always going to be chasing
something you're always going to be
looking for that thing that's next
that's going to fill the hole
and that thing will never come ever
it's not the new relationship it's not
the next kid it's not the bigger house
it's not even the growth-minded book
completion insight about the world
because every insight that you get
just leads you to wanting more it's
constantly chasing the rabbit
of productivity gains or of
money gains it doesn't just need to be
the hedonic treadmill it can simply be
the growth treadmill
and realizing that that's not a feature
sorry that's not a bug it's a feature
life is unsatisfactoriness
is a feature not a bug it's always going
to be there
what else would i put in i would say
question your assumptions around things
as well a lot of the time in 2021 it's a
meritocracy
people are what they do and we're so
busy
that we very rarely get the opportunity
to actually assess what we're doing what
did we say
about making changes and plans if this
is
for the rest of your life and you're
about to choose the trajectory that
you're going to go on
you better [ __ ] get it right like
you'd better
choose the right direction so
assessing your assumptions means do i
actually believe that i should be going
out and getting drunk every weekend
do i actually believe that it doesn't
matter if i cheat on my girlfriend
because the relationship's not going to
go anywhere anyway
do i and so on and so on just continue
to assess the assumptions that you've
got
the more that i sit back and do that and
question
is there an easier way for me to do this
is there a better way for me to do this
do i even need to do this these things
are important i would say that
fame doesn't matter but is still useful
and that's quite an embarrassing thing
for some people to admit because
accepting that you want fame makes you
sound a bit uncouth
makes you sound sort of a bit primal and
showy
but let me tell you like some of the
most useful things that have happened in
my life have been due to the fact that
people know me
it is never going to get boring or dull
being walked to the front of a queue and
put through a velvet rope in wherever it
is
whatever it is that you do and i can go
probably most of the continents on the
planet now and there'll be someone there
that owes me a favor in one kind or
another
that's a that's a good position to be in
so
it doesn't necessarily have to be about
the same you can get the fame but know
that it doesn't have to be about the
fame
and the same thing's true with money tim
o'reilly from o'reilly media has this
amazing quote where he says money is
like gasoline on a road trip
you need to make sure that you don't run
out of gas but you're not doing a tour
of gas stations either
if all that you do is spend your life
mindlessly accumulating wealth
you're not going to get anywhere you
need enough wealth to make sure that
you're not going to break down
and you need to never be out of the game
like how much
is enough how much is enough really
genuine question like is a million
pounds or a million dollars enough i i
i don't see a world in which i'm going
to have a million pounds or a million
dollars and think like oh yeah
but i wish it was i wish it was five why
so deprogramming some of that and then
definitely one of the final chapters
or one of the first chapters probably
would be working out what do you want to
want
this is a red pill i got from kyle
eschenroder who's been on the show
episode 189 anyone that wants to listen
to it on modern wisdom
amazing guy fantastic blog post a lot of
the time the things that we think that
we want aren't
true we think we want
fame or money or an easy life or
luxury or whatever it might be and when
we actually assess those assumptions
we realize that we don't care i don't
want
that it's just what other people want or
it's what my parents told me that i was
supposed
to want or it's what my genetic
programming wants me to do or it's what
the paths of least resistance are
do you want to spend tonight on netflix
well it feels like you do
but do you actually want to spend the
night watching netflix or would you
prefer
going to that open mic comedy club
with a couple of mates because tomorrow
you're not going to remember
what you even watched on netflix and
it's just going to be like a million of
the nights that you've spent but you
might actually
really enjoy the comedy club even if
it's a bit [ __ ]
even if the comedians suck you're gonna
have these memories about that night
that we went to that open mic night and
it was totally terrible mate
like this is assessing assumptions this
is working out what you truly want to
want
i mean the number of lessons that i've
got from the show
are essentially endless and will be
for as long as i don't get kicked off
apple podcasts and youtube so
i'll continue to grow like that but
those are certainly some of the big ones
i would maybe say
two lessons that i learned from aubry
marcus that really
hit me in the chest were
you do not serve other people from your
cup you serve them from the saucer which
overflows around your cup
and what you learn from that is that
you in order to serve you need to be fit
for service
if you want to be able to bear a burden
if you want to be able to lift a weight
if you want to be an impressive human
that helps other people
you need to be all that you can be
before you can help everybody else
in an aircraft malfunction the
instruction is you put
your mask on first before you help other
people because a person that's
suffocating is of little use
to everybody around them and there are
people out there who need you
there are people out there who want what
only you can give them because
only you can so i'll give you a little
preview of the tedx talk actually
in it i came up with something i called
um like the the weirdness imperative
which is that it is your duty to give
the world what only you can give it
because only you can as brilliant as he
was
da vinci didn't do dali and michelangelo
didn't do dali
anything other than the absolute truest
manifestation of dali's being would have
left the world
fundamentally less the likelihood of you
being alive is essentially zero
one in ten to the power of two million
six hundred and eighty five thousand
which is more particles than every
particle in the universe if
each particle was another universe
that's how big that number is it's
astronomically ridiculously big
and if you choose to not
do the thing which this insanely
unlikely series of events has caused you
to exist
to do the world will be fundamentally
less complex and beautiful
because you are not enacting what only
you can
so if you allow status games or social
norms or internal fears to curb your
weirdness you're not
giving the universe what you can this
isn't some
esoteric ephemeral wishy-washy new age
[ __ ]
this is how it works if you do what
everyone else does you get what everyone
else has got
but you deliver what everyone else
delivers
i don't need 7.7 billion people
all trying to race to the middle of the
distribution of the mean
i want 7.7 billion people all doing what
only they can
because that's the way that you get the
richest world that's the way that you
get the vastest
access to human potential and if you
think okay
i want to do something that really makes
a difference do what only you can
don't allow yourself to compromise
because of social norms or internal
fears
don't allow yourself to be pulled away
by
the the conception that you have around
what you should and shouldn't do
just do what you're supposed to do do
what you want to do if you go after that
i think
you'll probably end up in a pretty good
place so there's there's some chapters
of the book for you
amazing just when i thought i i couldn't
learn any more from you you go and hit
me with that
um chris this has been incredible thank
you so much if people want to go and
find you where can they go
uh modern wisdom wherever you listen
apple podcast spotify
youtube etc oh no sorry the youtube
channel is now chris williamson
uh and then chris will x chris will x
wherever you follow me
instagram twitter etc uh if you want to
be signed up to my newsletter just
chriswilex.com
and i send out her newsletter every
monday with some insights and some life
hacks
and there will be you mentioned about
books there will be a reading list
coming out
soon and that will be available on the
newsletter so just go to chriswellx.com
and you'll be alerted when that's live
amazing thank you so much
thank you very much for tuning in if you
enjoyed that then press here
for a selection of the best clips from
the podcast over the last few months
and don't forget to subscribe it makes
me very happy indeed
peace
you